circling way back earlier on okay uh
about passion projects yeah you know any
any passionate projects you've been
working on recently i've done the fake
one um i guess i don't i kind of don't
want to talk about it yeah i almost
don't want to turn up because because
like i talked about the fake video and
people were asking about me about it for
an entire year because like here here's
the thing when you're working on a
passion project yeah it feels great
you're just you just want to talk about
it you want to get it out and then you
forget that you have to make it as well
people have been asking i've been
writing that [ __ ] for years now it's
like when is it when is it coming out
and i'm like don't [ __ ] rush the
passion okay
i probably recorded one of my favorite
one of my favorite videos uh the other
day and it was just so fun and it was
very fun everything about it was great i
i filmed uh it should be out by the time
this is uh airing hopefully yeah if not
i guess it's a surprise
i filmed a video i worked at a gay bar
oh yeah yeah yeah it was uh it was very
fun they were just so welcoming everyone
oh yeah
it was a great time i i almost forgot i
had cameras on because i was having a
great time reacting and hanging out with
the boys like we were just
yeah they were just it was just so fun
especially in japan you know because uh
people are very closed off here yeah and
there's very much just having a guy be
like hey what's your dick size and i was
like whoa i'm glad you asked
well that's the way to break the ice
that's something you don't see in japan
especially right i haven't had this in
japan i haven't had this level of uh was
he a jojo fan
yes he was did he see an unsucked dick
it was after i sing i sang uh sort of
uh
oh no
yeah nice yeah in the like gay district
so you could just go and sing uh sing
anime songs yeah with the boys hell yeah
that sounds amazing it was such a fun
bar so welcoming it was just great and
uh yeah i just had an amazing time and
it was great and it's one of those
videos where
i didn't really think much about it
before i filmed it but i was like damn
this is probably one of the most fun
videos i've ever filmed that's the best
feeling just had drinks with the boys
yeah literally yeah it's really weird
actually meeting anime fans here in
japan because you talk to some of them
and it's almost like
it's even less popular than it is
outside of japan right
because it's it's really weird because
sometimes you meet an anime fan and you
say you watch anime as well they get so
excited yeah and they're they're just
like i thought i was the only one what's
your favorite anime and what would you
like watching and
and it's it's so weird because it's
almost being transported back like 10
years ago yeah except it's it's here in
japan i think i think it's because you
know in japan you know they don't have a
massive uh
social climate you know it isn't you
know people aren't exactly the most
social to one another yeah yeah and
especially
yeah and i think having a solid
icebreaker like you like anime yeah you
know it makes any anyone comfortable who
who if you if it doesn't matter who you
are if you both like anime you can talk
about something yeah yeah exactly i mean
like i feel like in japan where again
people aren't very socially outgoing
it's it's such a good icebreaker and a
very comfortable one yeah and i find
that especially when you're a foreigner
as well yeah people feel a lot more
comfortable talking to you because they
feel like oh you like the same things as
me even though you have a different
place yeah and it definitely makes them
feel more comfortable i feel it's
especially as well because unlike in the
west where like the whole like anime
community and like otaku thing is more
of like community based thing even in
real life here in japan it's very much
like a lone wolf type of thing like i
feel like yeah people don't talk about
it like the true like like hardcore
takus here
i mean for one don't really go out and
socialize
they oh be outside like you know being
like walking around being like i like
this thing do you like it like they're
not going to be like that they're going
to stick with like 2chan right and yeah
about their
passion there right obviously
but you know and i feel that's why like
especially in japan that's so much more
rare to come across yeah because for one
it's like
oh
i didn't know about this whole other
side of the community because a lot of
these attackers in japan
don't really interact with other people
in that even within the same community
let alone you know across the [ __ ]
ocean yeah because like you you hear in
japan and you you talk to a japanese
person and even if they're not an anime
fan they're like aware of like obviously
love a lot of anime because we're here
in japan but like you meet an actual
person who watch as who watches anime
and it's like i'm transported back to
like the early periods of when i got
into anime because i've never seen
someone's face just i've never seen a
japanese person's face light up so much
when you say you watch jojo or when you
say you watch some other like some other
anime that's maybe not ava or one piece
you know because those are like those
like the two mainstream anime here that
even like non-anime fans watch and i i
guess like that's just not what i
expected when i moved to japan because i
thought i thought at least like i didn't
know because i'd only heard about you
know the otaku culture from
basically from third hand accounts right
i'd never actually had experienced it
myself so i didn't know that anime fans
just are still
almost like underground here in some in
some senses right and that just kind of
like blew my mind yeah i mean i feel
maybe within like the past like say 10
20 years yeah like much like the west
right i feel it's become a little bit
more open and accepting and like you
know
you know like even in the west right
kids 10 20 years ago would get bullied
for watching anime now you get bullied
for not watching anything i feel in
japan it's kind of become the same thing
now except still at the end of the day
like the true like hardcore tuckers are
still very much underground because i
think i think they're scared to come out
yeah but but i feel like
you know you said that they're
underground but you know like every time
you watch a documentary anything about
japan and otaku's you always saw the
hardcore yeah they'd be like
this is
uh this is a
tanaka he's spent ten thousand dollars
this year on love life and it's like all
right great
yes but i think as well as as well
because like just the term otaku in
japan is just so much more than someone
who likes anime like yeah you have like
train or targets you have military or
tacos
the types of fans and like hardcore fans
that you wouldn't really see outside of
japan i saw a hardcore america otaku
oh did you actually at my train station
and this guy was wearing a full
uh what is it bald eagles
what was it what's the american eagles
bald eagle shirt yeah uh a cowboy hat
like a 10 like gallon one yeah he had
the pins of america on it
he's wearing
the bluest denim jeans i've ever seen
and he was wearing cowboy boots
and then he was just japanese and he was
wearing glasses and i was like this is
just so bizarre you should add my trash
and he was doing the like the [ __ ]
handsome
handsome belt waiting for the the state
of the train to come and i was like
what the [ __ ]
that's so cool
i wanted to be like konichiwa
i was just like this is so bizarre i was
like i want to know the background i was
like i want that guy to come on trash
taste like yeah
i want to do this dude
i don't know it's just like because like
especially like you know every now and
then when you go to like a train station
in japan especially like uh like the
shinkansen like the bullet trains you
sometimes see you know some train or
takers oh yeah yeah those are oh yeah
and they're always taking pictures with
these like massive like bird watching
people in the uk though as well as big
big uh
train spotting or whatever and uh the
planes yeah and you'll see them at the
airport yeah but like i always find like
that side of the otaku fan base to be
just so much more interesting i feel and
maybe it's because i know nothing about
it but also at the same time it's like
it feels so much more like mysterious
because you almost never see those kinds
of people interacting even within the
same community members because you also
you also see a lot more shows made about
uh
attackers traditional attackers i guess
for the anime yeah because it's just
like oh look at this guy he spends 20
grand a month on some png
yeah it's a lot easier to get it yeah
yeah that's the thing right is that they
want to these film crews just want
something weird it's really hard to just
make fun of a guy who just likes trains
you know you say what you will but a lot
of the time these documentaries that
would just would go into a dude's house
and be like wow look at him look at the
state he's got all these anime figures
you know they're trying to make fun of
it really yeah
i i i because i feel like there's such a
such a big divide between maybe like say
anime and then the otaku anime you know
what i mean basically like if if you see
if he if you see your series in like
akihabara or something then it's
probably gonna be looked down upon by a
lot of people in japan because i
remember we uh we hang out with our
friend's girlfriend and she was like a
mad like amado turkey remember
talking to her and she was like yeah i
got bullied in school for liking anime
i'm just like what
you're japanese what
how is this a thing
how how yeah i think it's so common that
it's almost cool to not like it and do
something else right yeah yeah